yeah interesting that you should mention
all that because one of the things i'm
trying and failing to do this weekend
along with everything else is
when i got to where i'm staying in
boulder there was a galley waving of a
book which will be published in october
by eric davis called technosis
and they want me to read it and do a
blurb for it which i'm happy to do it's
just a little inconvenient to try and
focus your mind in that way on the road
but he
[Music]
he is making the case very
eloquently
that the new information
technologies are in fact magical
technologies and related
to
hermes street mcgifus and the idea of
action at a distance which is a very
central idea in magical
theory
and he makes the point that i think i
made here yesterday or friday evening i
can't remember which is
but words which are power words which
make things happen
have been
that has been
uh sort of off the burning in the west
for a couple of centuries and have now
returned with the power of the of
the codes
that govern uh computational machinery
which he thinks of as communication
machinery that this is really
uh
what it's doing um
yeah one of the paradoxes or one of the
fascinating aspects of the 20th century
and the rise of
empiricism positivism rationalism
whatever you call all that
is that in a way
it has fulfilled the magical agenda of
the 15th and the 16th century
the agenda which was
transformation of the human form
immortality a universal panacea a
universal medicine
this this agenda enunciated by the
magical thinkers of the late middle ages
could never have been realized by their
message or at least we think not
but by putting aside
their message
and
deconstructing matters tearing into the
cell the genome and so forth and so on
now we
essentially can
extend
and prolong life
can
in a quasi-telepath manner communicate
around the world uh
have um
[Music]
you know created a world which i think
would be the the envy
of people like michael center
santavorgius and michael meyer and
[Music]
well all of the
great late
european alchemists you know we have a
kind of a most people i think have a a
kind of a
misconceived notion
of the history of occult thinking
in that if people tend to believe that
the further back in time you go the more
close unquote superstition
you encounter this is actually not true
at all the 12th century
the century when christendom was that
its grave death fluorescence
was an incredibly rational
period
ruled over by scholastic philosophy
ruled over by aristotle and aquinas
it is the breakup of the medieval world
and the injection of islamic elements
and the re-translation of for example
the hermetic texts and
many other magical and gnostic and
heretical text
that all happened in the renaissance
uh in in the 15th century and it sets
the stage for the 16th
which
was is the most demon-haunted paranoid
hysterical
century
in the last 10 centuries in the west
with the possible exception of our own
and it's in the 16th century and the
late 15th century that you get the witch
burnings
the
suppression of alchemical writing
and strangely enough the great
efflorescence of that writing because
alchemy
you know alchemy has sort of
is a spectrum and on one end you have
uh
pretty nuts and bolts laboratory type
procedures working with materials
working with flame and
and
heating and grinding and calcinating all
kinds of materials
but at the other end of the spectrum you
have what's called literary alchemy
which often
rarely comes near the laboratory and
produces instead
alchemical poetry for example
[Music]
there's a wonderful somewhat hard to
obtain book
called the tea atrium chemical
britannicum
that is a compendium of english
alchemical poetry produced in the early
late 15th early 16th century
uh beautiful and strange and this is
where uh you know the occult intent
meets with like the art of memory
and the uh as you mentioned the use of
emblems to to fix information
and the great
stress
in that late efflorescence of alchemy
and the cult thinking is the imagination
which again returns and illuminates all
of our themes here
you know the art of memory
uh as practiced in the late renaissance
consisted of
uh memorizing
large architectural spaces
public piazzas and cathedrals and town
plans and things like that and putting
this into your mind and then
moving through it i mean i suppose in a
buddhist context we would call this a
visualization
moving through this
familiar
territory and
for instance if you wanted to give a
speech about the seven deadly sins
then at prominent places in this mental
geography
you would
in your mind place outlandish images
and the stress was on outlandish because
the idea was they should be as memorable
as possible
so for instance in the place of uh
lust
to randomly choose one of the seven
deadly sins
you would image
a woman in a nun's habit but lifting her
skirts to reveal her genitals or
something shocking the idea was to be
shocked and then when you stood before
the
congress of venice or whatever august
body you were addressing
you would in a sense fall into a trance
and make this journey through this
mental building
and uh
and meet your emblemata at these places
where you had left them and then they
would trigger these associative
strings of verbiage and by this means i
mean this sounds a little hokey like
would it work could it work turns out
something about the human mind it works
very very well and some of the
oratorical feats
list recitation and stuff like this
that's recorded
is astonishing so
this is a
an interesting confluence of magical
intent
imaginative
landscapes and
information and communication
theory
and one time i
i experimented with this because my
undergraduate days were spent at the
university of california at berkeley
and i used to on the tail end of many an
acid trip
i would go up to what i called the big u
no pun intended or pun intended and
wander around the big u
and i got to know it so well it's nooks
and crannies it's staircases and trap
doors and back entries that it became
for me like a memory palace and i often
find myself in it when i'm in a public
speaking
situation
getting you know glimpses of recessional
distances of of hallways and staircases
and to classrooms and i realize you know
in my mind all that lingered i'm still
part of uh
the big youtuber
it is absolutely a virtual reality for
sure
um
oh by the way
establishing a crime is exactly what a
good writer is somehow
which part of it
i never i got this information a few
weeks ago but i never knew about the
evil technique
oh i see so a really good poet of
writers that
didn't mean the picture so strongly in
their mind that picture somehow looks to
the word not just a good use of words
beyonce picture comes true
that's right the audience or the reader
is getting into pictures telepathically
somehow yes they may not understand how
the trick is done
but good writers and good artists can
play these mechanical
underpinnings of of reality
for instance i worked on a on a film
project at one time and uh
and it was to it had four male
characters
in it and the
writer
brought in jung's uh
archetypes of the of the collective
unconscious and he said we'll we'll make
each guy
an icon
of one of the types of the unconscious
well this is magical and emblematic and
archetypal thinking where you pull
energy to the surface and it all looks
very mundane but you're actually using
the
the substructures of the human mind to
imbue
your characters with power uh in in the
reader's mind
um
yeah it's very interesting the you know
science believes that it's risen beyond
magic and that that's all part of our
past
i i think the future is for sure going
to be very magical and the practitioners
of the magical arts these days are uh
madison avenue for example where you
know the bottom line rests on how you
can shove these images into people's
minds and get them to stay there and i
don't know if you
leaf through these pretentious high-end
fashion magazines with the snarling and
the sexual models and all that
you realize that the more
jarringly
it presents itself as a non-sequitur the
longer you tend to linger over the ad
asking yourself the question
why
would the french perfume associate
itself with a pig in an automobile
accident and which is precisely what
you're supposed to be asking yourself i
mean if they gave you a woman in an
evening dress with a floral overlay this
is not going to stick very long
so
and it's up to us as citizens of these
quasi-magical societies to ever keep
educating ourselves in front of those
who would seek to control us it's a it's
a push you know it's a bootstrapping
process
if you're interested in
in the
history of
renaissance occult thinking there's a
wonderful world of scholarship
and beautiful writing i'm thinking
especially of dame francis yates
who wrote such books as
the art of memory giordano bruno and the
hermetic tradition
magic and mystery in the late plays of
shakespeare
so forth and so on
because i really though those aren't the
people i relate to that's the legacy i
look back on and i'll say something
about this actually just
because i will
a lot of times people send me email and
and they want to know
what do you think of aleister crowley
what do you think of madame blavatsky
and i realize there's a great interest
and
hunger out there in
the psychedelic demographic
for this occult
information and and what i always write
back and usually to the disappointment
of my
interlocutors
is uh
that i
think magic was pretty trivial after
elias levy after the mid 19th century or
even before
and it's just a failure of people's
education you know if you're interested
in
great magicians
you should know that aleister crowley is
late derivative and and not tapped into
the main vein it's no fault of his it's
just his position in historical time
but if you go back to marcelo facino
and um uh trethemius bishop of sponheim
uh henry cornelius agrippa
funmettelsheim
uh paracelsus john d edward kelly
robert flood
you see the great
watershed in european
[Music]
in the development of the european mind
in the past 500 years
is the 30 years war
which in america people don't even know
you know it's taught it's called in
america the protestant reformation which
is a pretty gutless description of the
30 years war the 30 years war
la begins in 1619
and goes until 1648.
yeah no it's not 30 years but hey they
were rounding off
and at the beginning of the 30 years war
europe is ruled by popes and kings and
the magical mentality is unchallenged at
the end of the 30 years war europe is
ruled by parliaments and peoples and the
royal society has been established in
england newton is beginning his early
work
descartes is articulating his thought
and we are at the brink of modernity and
this is was the greatest tidal change
in the west since uh constantine
embraced christianity
so uh and
it would never have happened i maintain
in quite the way that it did happen if
psychedelics had been part of the menu
of european
experience
that transition to
[Music]
positivism and rationalism almost
required isolation from the psychedelic
experience because
the psychedelic experience raises too
many questions that positivism would
prefer not to deal with it's the
it's the rise of psychedelic use in the
in the west since 1950 that has brought
all this back
uh in in the
1950s you could buy alchemical
literature two three hundred year old
books almost by the truckload for
nothing i mean it was it was wall filler
it was landfill materials just people
said well this is the raving of the late
medieval mind these superstitious
deluded souls
now of course that's all
incredibly expensive material and many
artists
have mined those alchemical themes very
successfully because um you know
uh
you you can change the surface
the social surface but you can't really
change the archetypal architectonics of
the human mind and we gravitate to these
spaces we we want transcendence and
the the
connecting thread through all of this i
think
is the imagination
and
what science needs to become
is more uh
open
to the magical
possibilities to
to the irrational to the intuitional the
emotional ultimately
[Music]
[Music]
you